Cat Face was accompanying Box Cat to his children's sports day.
So, what happens here?
Running and the jumping?
When is it finishing time so I can go flip above my chair at them.
What?
Relative's participation?
Well then, that is the job for me.
I thrive on the competition.
Is there a prize?
A chocolate medal?
Well, come on! I will be covering my face in success before the day is through.
Yes.
What is first?
The egg and the spoon.
Well, I am all over this. Yes!
Come on, you ovoid, let's get with the balancing.
That's it, my little egg friend.
Nice and easy with delicious little thing.
What is it with the bad-mouthing there, honestly.
What is up next Box Cat?
A sack race, you say?
Well, that might be a bit more up my street.
Look at this funny little sack.
Look, Box Cat, I am the ghost of sporty past.
No. What? I can't see!
Yes, I have seen your chocolate medal.
I hope you choke on the victory, you sack monkey!
What do you mean take it more seriously?
What does one have to do to get the delicious melty medally treat?
A big surprise?
I'm sure I have a muffin somewhere.
The next race for the relatives will be the three-legged race.
That's the three-legged race over by the starting line thank you.
Right. This one must be mine!
Old lady?
Yes Possums?
Limber up!
This race, we cannot lose.
Quick!
Possums!